bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono favi geri ed oggi siamo
sullo speciale di fi che cosa stanno
facendo i miei capelli si stanno
impossessando del mio corpo sarò breve
in questo video che la vedo dura siccome
durante l'anno ragazzi ho fatto una
marea di videogiochi horror oltre a
quelli divertenti
ho raccolto in un video sono tutti i 50
spaventi più assurdi che mi sono preso
durante l'anno quindi ragazzi spero che
vi piaccia l'unica cosa che vi voglio
dire prima di farmi partire e che
previamente ragazzi quando io mi prendo
uno spavento sfogo questo mio spavento
dicendo roba tipo ma [ __ ] porca [ __ ]
succede perché è normale perché quando
ti prendi uno spavento della madonna non
è che ti viene da dire perdincibacco che
spavento proprio no se vi dà
particolarmente fastidio sentire dire
parole tipo [ __ ] non lo guardate
fatte prima perché sono un casino rosso
di però prima di iniziare basta e quindi
ragazzi preparatevi per le prime 25
perché poi si entra un po più nell'arco
e facciamo una pausa di riflessione
let's go per c'è problema è che possa
arrampicarmi sull'armadio cosa devo fare
se non ci 25 prezzo immenso quindi posso
buona porca [ __ ] è veramente
[ __ ] allora allora allora allora
anche se piuttosto di madre madre dona
molto symbol successo ma va fazio e
fitto costa merda ladra [ __ ] se devo
passarla così
mi fanno pitch ares i quadri belli sera
ho perso ma tu lo dici file a 4 anni non
ce la fa ma anche tua madre che è più
pronta di goethe lo giuro lo trovate a
farmi fare inferi che sono fermi che se
lo fai mi cacci
oddio ma se ami con il bambino sei amico
dei topi non sei amico dei topi ok io
non so quale il peggio tra di tua madre
fa le torte ma quelle brutte no siamo
alla fine bastava [ __ ] basta dobbiamo
andare e morta così ragazzi motivi non è
morta hai raccolto cuore [ __ ] ah
scusate mi regalo non vi avevo visto
l'accordo ragazzi sopravvissuti alle
prime 25
adesso le prossime 15 fino ad arrivare
alla top ten pronte lesbica di quella
[ __ ]
quindi dovevo passarle di più qualche
noia
ragazzi così
porca [ __ ] che gi ronchi adottato
cosa facciamo qui ci nascondiamo in
soffitta guarda che ti ho già visto
ok tua sorella
la cosa fai
gli harlem affanculo [ __ ] cosa è
successo non c'è veramente fatemi cagare
in pace anche a [ __ ]
cuore c'è nulla che marino questo così
non posso prenderlo grazie
[Musica]
sto iniziando a sentire rumori
bruttissimi non fosse normale
ok ma capraia lo sapevo che è successo
mi si è chiuso tutto c'è un secchio
posseduto sapevo lo sapevo
perfetto ragazzi adesso si entra nelle
prime dieci quindi tenetevi forte perché
sono pesanti via sto prendendo delle
candele acacus un quadro l'immagine sarà
la porta lei non è lì ho sentito questo
urlo da lontano ma [ __ ] [ __ ]
basta che cazzo è caduto sotto alle
porte è veramente proprio le nostre 32
euro
[ __ ] fuori che a trovare casa e
veloce
c'è un pennarello volante fargli
gardiner iosa credo che bello
e allora ti prendo testa e le prime tre
in classifica ragazzi sono tu non ti
giri e te ne vai a [ __ ]
la madre che cuba di gelati e non è
proprio il massimo della vita per o mio
dio c'è anche stare in compagnia lista
casa dove cazzo e fossimo non ci crederò
mai ma [ __ ] è al primo posto in
assoluto ragazzi ho scelto lo spavento
uno spavento che mi sono preso d'impatto
diciamo tutta la scena e sono stato
terrorizzato quindi non vedrete tipo io
che salta dalla sedia ma siccome mi
fanno un po paura i ragni e successo
questo no no no io ragni e non regalate
di ragni noi non ce la fanno sul serio a
parte gli scherzi non ce la faccio
no ragazzi non ce la posso fare no no no
no no no no no ragazzi
toglietemi con lo schifo non ce la posso
fare tutta una primis registra sveglia
perché io ci ho paura ho paura di ragni
ci ho paura no no no no no no no che
schifo di me che schifo è quindi ragazzi
queste 150 spaventi più assurdi che mi
sono preso durante l'anno se le vostre
cuffie non si sono ancora rotte dopo
questi ruoli mascolini proprio
complimenti e quindi ragazzi per
concludere volevo soltanto dirvi grazie
per quest anno magnifico auguro a tutti
quanti voi ragazzi un anno ancora
migliore però di rallegrarvi le giornate
un po di più con i miei video che
cercano di far uscire sempre una volta
giorno vi ringrazio ancora per
quest'anno meraviglioso e auguro un buon
anno a tutti stampate champagne e alcol
vodka di no vabbè tra tranquille quindi
ragazzi per concludere se il vino è
piaciuto ma solito lasciato commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
ogni video trovate la descrizione
terroristi discreti ci vediamo il
prossimo video belle ragazze